en est à dire trouve des trucs
incroyables pour la chaîne cryptée la
chaîne cryptée en italie en a pas mal et
il ya des gens pour découvert un truc
formidable c'est ça s'appelle le truc de
la passoire regarder
[Musique]
c'est tout à fait sérieux non en italie
d'aujourd'hui
ont déconné c'est le triptyque c'est pas
soit une deux trois passes voir le
décodeur avant marche des décodeurs bon
marché
on se fait des lunettes passoire et dans
la région de naples m'a-t-on dit
aujourd'hui on ne trouve plus une
passoire sur le marché le bruit était
effectivement significative de la
situation qu'on veuille à la télévision
effectivement dans cette passoire j'en
apprécie sur canal+ et ça marche
peut-être alors essayé après tout suffit
d'une bonne manière de faire encore que
la grosse passoire en plastique joue pas
très bien quoi elle même